hi i'm tim cavanaugh for recent TV we're
here with Jim Newton editor at large at
the LA Times opinion section and author
of the new book Eisenhower at the White
House years Jim thanks for joining us
question for old colleagues so it's good
to catch up with an old LA Times hand
and there was a biography a couple years
ago in Michael kurta of Eisenhower's war
years and this sort of picks up the
thread to some extent of covering just
the presidency which is as I think you
make a pretty good case in the book
really underrated I hope that comes
through in the book I do think it's a
period of enormous change in the United
States son really effective presidency
somewhat to my surprise I've done a
previous book on Chief Justice Earl
Warren who was not a fan of Eisenhower
after he'd been appointed and so I came
to this book with some skepticism about
how I would come off and came away
mightily impressed by how much did I
work at that underestimation it's not in
the book but there's an old fable about
Ike that at some point he told an aide
well if I get into trouble I'll just
perplex them with mice in tears I'll
confuse them yeah exactly yeah I think
part of it is quite deliberate there is
as you say a sort of sense lowering
expectations for himself also his
golfing his vacationing obviously
something he enjoyed and was important
for his health particularly after his
heart attack but he also really saw it
as he took it on himself quite
self-consciously
to try to lower the sense of crisis in
the country that he felt FDR and Truman
had perpetuated and he was gonna sort of
calm the country down it's one thing I
always appreciated about Ike is you know
he spent basically his entire adult life
in taxpayer-funded institutions at one
kind or another and yet was always very
skeptical of calls to sacrifice for the
greater good the best example I think is
in Sputnik the establishment media went
sort of crazy after Sputnik saying how
you know we had to retool the education
system walter Lippmann had a great thing
in the LA Times about this is what comes
of doing nothing but looking at better
consumer goods basically the same
argument the Khrushchev made
and yet Ike was very much about you know
we shouldn't be panicking over Sputnik
we don't want to kind of make all these
big changes well one of the things that
people forget
I kept the benefit of the You Tube
program when Sputnik went off so he knew
knew better than the American people did
the capacities and so you know and its
lack of capacity they were really quite
uh none by the whole thing it's only
once the American people got kind of
whipped up and nervous about it that the
administration felt an obligation to
react but the role of Ike's brothers you
it's been interesting I didn't even know
I had any brothers and it was it was
very interesting to see their
correspondence with I talked a lot about
the middle way as the sort of style and
approach of his presidency and I think
it's easy to see that being the sort of
outgrowth of his family he was the third
of six brothers they grew up in a house
smaller than the office that he had when
he worked in the Pentagon so you know
it's a rough-and-tumble
family and then within those brothers
among his older brothers Edgar was quite
conservative and among his younger
brothers Milton was quite liberal and if
you look at the correspondence between
Ike and Edgar and Milton you often see
him being sort of tugged in two
directions by a gentleman almost always
ending up with Milton by the way he has
a much more contentious correspondence
with his brother Reggie you present Ike
as unexpectedly progressive character
certainly by today's standards it would
represent a quite liberal segment of the
Republican Party but you know when he
had opposition when he had to fight for
things in Congress yeah just as often
had to fight the right wing of his own
party as liberals McCarthy was a
consistent pain for him waist in the
first couple of years later a bill
Noland and the China first folks really
were troublesome part of the party for
him to deal with in in foreign affairs
particularly in Taiwan and China highway
system is a good example I think of him
really not being banned to a kind of
Republican orthodoxy on the other side
civil rights I found it difficult to
find a sort of progressive course in
civil rights I don't think he really
felt it was hard he ended up having
quite a good record on civil rights but
in some ways despite himself where do
you stand on the idea that the the 50s
were where the real movement happened in
civil rights not the six yeah I think
that's accurate in terms of I mean
obviously there were movements across
both decades but you know Brown versus
Board of Education obviously is 54 you
know the the Montgomery bus boycott the
rise of Martin Luther King all of that
for the most part is in the night
50 and Ike's contribution to that was
indirect but profound he appointed her a
Warren he appointed William Brennan both
the Supreme Court and of course these
big most you know memorable contribution
is in 1957 in the Little Rock crisis
since the subtext was civil rights it
had the effect of him being a champion
of civil rights like as a TV president
how much do you think of him as a sort
of modern image based president well is
it's the first presidency to run with a
jingle a modern TV sense that of course
the growth of television throughout the
nineteen fifties is it's explosive he's
the first president to really work with
the medium and you worked with an
advertising agency in 52 and again in 56
to make the most out of his image he
didn't have the television presence
obviously the Kennedy data but he
understood its its potential and I think
it was the first to really take
advantage of it in that sense
I can the federal spending with the
caveat that he passed the highway bill
and building you know started the
interstate highway system
we're started to connect it at another
later point in this presidency there was
a stimulus on the table that would have
been just for infrastructure which he
opposed because he didn't think the
states were ready for it that's a pretty
interesting lesson for the 2009 RS
stimulus which you know as we and can
now see a lot of the states just ended
up using those infrastructure funds to
pay for general fund expenses or
otherwise move funds around and so that
actually not much highway got built or
anything like that did we see a bright
line for a president two things to think
about with respect to Eisenhower I think
in the kind of modern economic context
are one as I said earlier I don't think
he was ever locked to a kind of
ideological position in the sense that
it would cause him to refuse to engage
in stimulus he was willing to build
highways he's willing to build a sample
st. Lawrence Seaway but he also believed
very strongly in balanced budgets he
inherited a significant deficit from
Harry Truman he left the country with a
surplus he believed in balanced budgets
not just for the sake of balanced
budgets but for the money that he felt
that it would liberate if the economy
were on sound footing to pay for a
spending including military spending I
believe very strongly in mutual aid and
support for American allies and he
believed that we were engaged in a very
expensive Cold War where the Soviet
Union in China
and deficits been into his mind robbed
the country of the money it needed to
spend on those priorities so he was not
he was not a liberal he was not a
tax-and-spend liberal by any means I
think he was less bound though
ideologically then either side is today
and the conversation about the economy
the good case for eisenhower now prior
to your book has always been the
military-industrial complex speech and
how much of that you should be credited
for what is so striking about the
farewell address in which he talks about
the military-industrial complex is he
assigns it to this sort of ominous quasi
governmental entity that no one had
really thought of any calls it a complex
which gives it a special kind of a
portent I think that the the fears that
he was expressing the concern about the
warping of American policy to serve a
military need was there throughout I
think he put it in particularly vivid
terms and it was particularly memorable
because he said it as a farewell I think
there's parting words of this great
general president are so unexpected I
think for so many people though they
really resonate an interesting point
about Ike's post presidency and we're
not finished cuz I want to do there
something I want to go back to but when
President Kennedy was assassinated was
saddened and yet was a little bit put
off by the kind of mawkish morning we're
just coming off the 10-year anniversary
of 9/11 and that's an interesting trait
yeah I don't want to be careful to
characterize that correctly that
observation comes mostly from his son
John Eisenhower who was very helpful to
me and the final stages of this book in
particular and John wanted to be sure
not to make it sound as though his
father were uncaring he cared about the
loss of the Kennedy for his children and
whatnot but in general he had sent many
men to their deaths
he understood sacrifice for the country
in a kind of basic way I think he was a
little taken aback by the national kind
of convulsion over Kennedy's death which
is not again to take away from real
sadness about it but I think he was
surprised at how seized up the country
was about it yeah speaking of sending
people to their deaths that certainly
happened when he was president we have
the interventions in Iran and Guatemala
there's two ways to look at the
Eisenhower record I think the war record
one in terms of American combat
Eisenhower inherited the Korean
ending it within seven months who
brought it to an armistice anyway from
that point forward the entire sum total
of combat casualties
for the US and the Eisenhower years is
one soldier who was killed by sniper in
Lebanon during the invasion there the
rest is through covert operations and
the Eisenhower strategy for containing
the Soviet Union was really twofold
which was to keep the Soviet Union
within its borders by the threat of
nuclear deterrence and to roll it back
through the use of covert action and he
did so quite enthusiastically in Iran
and Guatemala and then of course there's
Indonesia and there's other places
around the world where he's using covert
action sometimes successfully sometimes
unsuccessfully but in a deliberate and
attempt to keep the Soviet Union on the
defensive Nixon comes off surprisingly
well and and you know it's certainly
sympathetic in this book and actually
honourable in some ways that you
wouldn't have expected yeah I get a good
mostly good but somewhat complicated
relationship not never one of equals
even through his presidency I tried to
move him off the ticket for the 1956
campaign I thought that Nixon would
benefit by running a major Department
Department of Defense he suggested to
him and I think part of that is a
paternalism he thought that Nixon was so
political that actually running
something would be good for his
development and there's a as you can
tell all kind of paternalism about that
Nixon resisted understand incorrectly as
a politician that would be seen as a
demotion and that it would hurt him on
the other hand I do see a stick way back
Nixon and 1960 was sort of frustrated
that Nixon wouldn't use him more in the
campaign and was bitterly disappointed
that Nixon lost it Kennedy saw it as a
real repudiation of himself an election
not unlike I would say the election of
Barack Obama the ways that Obama ran
against the bush record Kennedy sort of
did against the Eisenhower record and so
I took it quite personally and live just
long enough to see Nixon elected
president which he also was enthusiastic
about and of course his grandson married
Nixon's daughter so the families now are
quite intertwined as well it was great
talking to you likewise Tim nice to see
you